- I think the New York City subway system,
it's the heartbeat of the city.
There is nothing that is
more New York than hearing
the cadence of a subway
car coming down the tracks
and into the station.
- Every train that goes by
is just a different rhythm.
(man beatboxes)
The hidden gems, are the
million dollar talent
that you find in the subway.
- Almost since the emergence
of the subway system,
when it opened in 1904,
people have realized
that it's actually quite
a great space to perform.
- I've been singing all my life.
I use what I have, and
the echo of the subway.
I don't need a microphone.
- I like to think of it as really more,
as the subway as muse.
And, that's been true all the way
from Duke Ellington's Take the A Train,
to, you know, Sean Carter
adopting the name Jay-Z,
from the J/Z lines.
- It really is a one of a kind experience.
And you're gonna get on
a train, a vintage train,
that came on line in the
'30s, and you're gonna pull
out of our station.
And, you're gonna take
that train in service up
to your final destination,
which is Willem de Kooning's
loft, which is incredible.
And, along the way, you're going to be
in an immersive, artistic experience.
- This was so cool.
- I had a full sensory overload.
- What is this old train
full of people and music?
- Definitely like, an unreal experience.
- It was so cool that you
went from car to car and,
were transported through time
with all different performances.
- Definitely like, a one
of a kind experience.
Chase Sapphire did it.
Now, my morning commute is ruined.
- So, it's truly, a once
in a lifetime opportunity
to be a part of an iconic
New York experience
on the subway.
Be exposed to some incredible artists,
who are inspired by the subway.
And then, to have a
great party afterwards.